Hallo, Jusuf ist mein Name und ich bin der zuständige Arzt hier auf dieser Station.
Wie heißen Sie? Ja, ich habe erst mal Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden.
Was machen Sie hier bitte? Sind Sie hier der Pfleger? Nein, ich bin der zuständige Arzt auf dieser Station.
Sie sind der Arzt hier, also sehen Sie aber gar nicht aus. Sie sind ja sehr jung.
Ja, danke schön. Sie sind der Arzt? Ich bin allgemein Arzt jetzt.
Wo haben Sie studiert? In der Stadt Konya in der Türkei.
Oh, dort gibt es auch Ärzte, wirklich? Ja, klar.
Ja, gut. Gut, sind Sie der einzige Arzt hier oder gibt es noch andere Ärzte, zu denen ich gehen kann?
Leider jetzt bin ich der zuständige.
Okay, dann muss ich wohl mit Ihnen sprechen.
Sie sind den guten Herrn, dafür machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Ja, sind Sie sicher? Dann werden wir das gleich mal sehen.
Ja, genau. Darf ich Ihren Namen ein bisschen? Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Klaus Sandstein.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen bitte langsam bustervieren?
Also ich bitte Sie. Klaus, den Namen kennt man doch ja. Klaus ist K. W. Karl, L. Ludwig, A. W. Anton, U. W. Ute und S. W. Siegfried.
Klaus, ganz einfach. Ja, für die Dokumentation, das erforderlich, deswegen.
Und Sandstein ist der Nachname. Sand, S. A. N. D. und Stein, wie Stein?
Ganz klar, Herr Sandstein. Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin genau geboren, ich bin geboren am 28. Juli 1979.
Alles klar. Und wie viel wegen Sie?
Das spielt eine Rolle, Herr Doktor, was sollen diese Fragen? Ich komme hier, weil ich ein Problem habe und Sie fragen mich nach meinem Gewicht.
Ja, diese sind Routinefragen, die wir fragen müssen.
Wenn Sie nicht Probleme hören wollen, dann kann ich auch woanders hingehen, ja?
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, für diese Dokumentation, diese Informationen sind sehr wichtig.
Ja, aber das habe ich doch vorne bei der Anmeldung schon gesagt. Warum fragen Sie mich denn noch mal?
Also das ist ja komisch, sowas habe ich auch noch nicht erlebt.
Alles klar, dann. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Also der Grund, warum ich zu Ihnen komme ist, ich habe seit zwei Tagen Luftnot und so einem Druck auf der Brust durch, kann mich schlecht belasten.
Seit zwei Tagen?
Ja.
Wie hat er es angefangen?
Wir sind sich, ich bin Handwerk auf dem Beruf, ich arbeite auf der Baustelle und da muss man schon kräftig arbeiten.
Und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich immer zunehmend schlechter Luft bekomme.
Und seit heute verspüre ich auch so ein enge Gefühl und ein Druck auf der Brust.
Nach einer Belastung hat es angefangen, ne?
Das hat schon mit Luftnot her.
Ohne Belastung.
Ohne Belastung, im Ruhe, meine Sie, aufgetreten, ne?
Jetzt in Ruhe, vorher aber wenn ich gearbeitet habe, ist mir das aufgefallen.
Jetzt merke ich, nun nehme ich...
Haben Sie früher so eine Schmerzen, diese enge Gefühl oder das erste Mal aufgetreten?
Das ist das erste Mal, so was habe ich vorher noch nie gehabt. Deswegen bin ich jetzt bei Ihnen.
Wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen drückend, eher oder stechend?
Ne, stechend ist es nicht, sondern ein komischer Druck, als ob da so ein Stein drauf liegen würde.
Woher ist die Schmerz?
Ach so, hier in der Mitte.
Hinter dem Brustbein oder eher steht im Magengrober?
Schwer zu sagen, das ist der gesamte vordere Bereich, sowohl auf der Brust als auch in der Magengrober.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen in eine andere Klöperregion aus oder?
Nein, ich merke hier vorne.
Als ich merke, wenn ich laufe oder arbeiten möchte, dann wird die Luft knapp.
Und ich merke, dass auch dieses enge Gefühl dann auch schlimmer wird.
Wie stark ist die Schmerz jetzt, zum Beispiel auf eine Schmerzgala von 1 bis 10?
Das ist mehr so ein Druck als so richtige Schmerz, würde ich nicht sagen.
Es ist eher ein Druck, ein enge Gefühl.
So Sie können nicht beschreiben, ne?
Ich sage ja, es ist eher ein Druck.
Also Schmerzen, hatte ich schon mal einen Beinscheinvorfall.
Da weiß ich schon, was Schmerzen sind und das ist anders.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen lehndat oder verschlechtert?
Sie haben erst mal diese Belastung gesagt, ob es noch weitere Ursachen gibt?
Nein, das ist so, wie ich es Ihnen gesagt habe.
Ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen noch keine Schmerzmedikamente genommen,
noch auszuhalten war.
Ich dachte, das geht wieder vorbei.
Aber das wird jetzt immer schlimmer.
Deswegen wollte ich zuerst zu Ihnen, bevor ich da irgendetwas mache.
Diese Druckgefühl ist dauerhaft da oder es kommt und weg?
Ich habe Sie doch schon gesagt.
Also es ist Zeit gestern, wird es zunehmend schlimmer.
Das ist nicht immer da, aber es wird immer schlimmer.
Alles klar.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich versuche zu arbeiten,
Treppensteige oder Laufel, dann wird es noch schlimmer.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Bein-Ödeme?
Was heißt Bein-Ödeme?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Was ist das?
Das habe ich nicht, aber ich merke Schmerzen in meiner Wade.
Auf der linken Seite.
Das scheint mir auch ein bisschen geschwollen zu sein.
Aber seit wann ist das geschwollen?
Ich habe gerade gesagt, Herr Doktor, hören Sie mir nicht zu?
Ja, wegen der akustischen Zeichen.
Das ist circa seit zehn Tagen so.
Haben Sie eine Temperaturunterschied oder ein Lungsdiches bemerkt
bei Ihren Beinen oder Waren?
An der Waren, meinen Sie?
Nein, ich habe nichts bemerkt.
Oder Rötungen?
Nein, Rot ist es nicht, aber etwas geschwollen.
Haben Sie einen Durchfall oder Verstöpfung?
Nein, was hat das damit zu tun?
Haben Sie sich erbrochen oder war Ihnen übel in dieser Zeit?
Nein, ich habe da nichts.
Sobbrennen?
Nein.
War Ihnen schwindel oder haben Sie Gangbildstörung?
Gangbildstörung, alles andere ist normal.
Da habe ich jetzt keine Probleme.
Ist die Gang normal wie immer?
Ja, warum fragen Sie das?
Ich habe kein Problem mit dem Laufen.
Ja, das frage ich.
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Was hat das jetzt mit der Luftmutter zu tun?
Warum fragen Sie mich?
Ich möchte ein umfassendes Bild der kranken Geschichte zu haben.
Deswegen frage ich.
Das ist ein bisschen komisch, aber gut, Sie sind der Doktor.
Danke schön.
Gibt es bei Ihnen wichtige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte, oder leiden Sie unter
einer dauerhaften Krankheit, wie zum Beispiel
Zuckerkrankheit, Diabetes, Zuckerkrankheit,
erhöhte Blutdruck, erhöhte Fettwerte, sonstige?
Ja, ich gehe sehr selten zum Arzt, weil ich ein sehr selten
krank bin.
Von daher war ich bis hier eigentlich nie richtig krank.
Ich hatte mal vor 10 Jahren einen Bandscheinvorfall,
aber das war relativ schnell wieder besser nachkriegen
nach Krankengymastik.
Sonst habe ich jetzt nichts, ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Meine Mutter hatte mal Diabetes gehabt,
sie ist leider verstorben vor 2 Jahren.
Woran hat sie gestorben?
Sie hat leider einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Und bei Ihrem Vater,
da ist es wichtige Krankheiten, oder ist er gesund?
Mein Vater hat auch wirklich ein paar Krankheiten,
ich weiß es nicht, aber so weit, ich weiß,
hat er, glaube ich, mehr.
Was hat da Problematik?
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich weiß,
dass es eine Prozessank-Problematik gibt.
Daher habe ich mich beim Urlauben,
der hat einen hohen Blutdruck,
weil ich weiß, er nimmt Medikamente.
Noch ein paar Sachen, aber das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Diese Bandscheinvorfall,
die Sie erwähnt haben,
ist medikamentös behandelt.
Damals habe ich Krankengymnasie,
Schmerzmedikamente bekommen.
Jetzt nehme ich aber nichts ein.
Wann war es, bitte?
Also vor ca. 10 Jahren.
Wurde bei Ihnen
eine Operation durchgeführt?
Nein, ich wollte keine Operation.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Nein, auch jetzt habe ich keine Medikamente genommen.
Ich war Ihnen alleggi oder um Fetterecklichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, schade.
Herr Sandsstein, rauchen Sie?
Bitte?
Rauchen Sie?
Oder hatten Sie geraucht?
Nein, ich rauche weiterhin.
Seit wann rauchen Sie und wie viel?
Nachkunft.
Ich rauche seitdem ich 25 bin, also ca. 20 Jahre.
20 Jahre?
Ich bin eine halbe Nacht am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol regelmäßig?
Ab und zu mal beim Fest oder so,
aber ansonsten trinke ich keine Alkohol.
Das ist eine routine Frage,
die wir jedem Patienten fragen.
Waren Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen?
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe schon drei Impfungen.
Ich hatte auch schon mal eine Infektion.
Wann war das?
Februar.
Sie haben gesagt,
seit zehn Tagen die Beine geschwollen.
Waren Sie?
Ja, geschwollen sind, aber waren Sie deswegen...
Nur das linke Bein, das weichte ich nicht.
Ja, linke.
Waren Sie deswegen in Arzt?
Nein.
Es hat mir auch keine großen Schmerzen gemacht.
Ich dachte, das ist eine Muskelzero.
Das geht wieder vorbei.
Sind Sie Bausteller?
Bitte?
Sie arbeiten in Baustellen.
Ja, ich arbeite auf der Baustelle.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Wir haben immer Stress an Doktor.
Was glauben Sie?
Sie waren im Ausland in den letzten zehn Tagen.
Ja, wie meinen Sie?
Sind Sie in der letzten zehn Tagen?
Im Ausland nicht, aber ich war im Urlaub.
Wo waren Sie?
Haben Sie eine lange Reise gemacht?
Wir waren mit dem Auto unterwegs.
Wir waren an der Nordsee.
Das sind von uns aus.
Wir waren mit dem Auto gefahren.
Wohne Pause?
Ja, schon durch eine Pause.
Aber die meisten Zeit sind wir gefahren.
War Ihnen schwindelig in der letzten Zeit
wegen dieser aktuelle Beschwerde?
Wir waren nicht schwindelig.
Herr Doktor, jetzt haben Sie mir so viele Fragen gestellt.
Was ist das jetzt?
Wir sind fertig unser Gesprächs.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Das wurde aber auch nur gesprochen.
Schauen Sie mal untersuchen Sie, was das ist.
Das ist etwas gefährliches.
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Jetzt ist es zu früh etwas zu sagen.
Ja, klar.
Ja, jetzt ist es zu früh etwas zu sagen.
Ja, klar. Sie haben mich auch noch nicht untersucht, Herr Doktor.
Also ich bitte Sie, dann machen Sie doch was schon.
Ja, ich werde mir gleichzeitig machen, diese Untersuchungen
und rechtzeitig Sie Bescheid sagen.
Alles klar.
Was wollen Sie mir Bescheid sagen?
Über die Ergebnisse, Laboruntersuchungen
gegebenenfalls machen wir bei Ihnen
eine CT-Untersuchung.
Was ist ein CT, Herr Doktor?
CT ist Computer-Tomographie.
Das heißt, Sie sind
eine Musik-Sein-Sonne-Röhre, die Weide-Wandschein-Profer.
Ja, aber
wie ich dich ist,
Sie haben keine Platzangst, ne?
Ein bisschen Schoner in so einer Röhre möchte ich nicht unbedingt, wenn es nicht sein muss.
Ja, gegebenenfalls werde ich bei Ihnen gemacht
wird, diese Untersuchung.
Aber es beinhaltet ein bisschen Bestrahlung.
Aber muss ich das gleiche, wo man in so eine Röhre reingibt?
Ja, Sie sind eine Röhre geschoben.
Oh je, also das gefällt mir nicht so.
Ja, aber das ist eine schmerzlose Untersuchung.
Ja, aber trotzdem, also bei der Bandscheibe war es auch sehr unangenehm.
Da liegt mehr halbe Stunde in so eine Röhre und dann
bekommt man schon etwas Platzangst und sie wissen, ich habe Druck und Luftnot.
Was ich möchte, dass nicht haben, wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss.
Ja, jetzt werde ich Sie so schnell wie möglich
ein Sauerstoff geben, danach werden Sie, ich hoffe, ein bisschen besser.
Ich sage Dankeschön.
Warum haben Sie das schon vorher gegeben?
Das hat jetzt eine ganze Stunde gebraucht, der Doktor.
Ja, Sie haben Recht.
Dann bis später.
Jetzt werde ich mit meinem Kollegen
eine Rückhaltung machen.
Eine Rücksprache halten.
Rücksprache, ja, genau.
OK.
OK, also weiß ich, bekommen wir jetzt ein EKG, haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Oder eine Blutabnahme?
Ja, natürlich, weil Sie Brustschmerzen haben.
Dann werden wir ein EKG, Blutabnahme
und auch können wir
Ultrischal machen bei ihr.
Also bitte, bitte, bitte zu arbeiten.
Ist mir schön, wenn man das etwas schneller machen kann.
Ja, ja, dafür machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Ja, ja, aber Sie reden ja auch schon sehr lange.
Sie sagen, dass die ganze Zeit, aber ich mache mir Sorgen, Doktor.
Ja, das machen wir schnell.
Das will ich hoffen.
OK, dann bitte fangen Sie gleich an.
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag. Wer sind Sie, bitte?
Ich bin aber als mein Name ist Kindes.
Ein bisschen Oberrat.
Ja, Herr Sannstein,
unser Kollege hat mich aus der Notaufnahme angerufen.
Ja.
Sie brauchen keine Angst, aber wir schauen uns alles gleich an.
Jetzt haben wir eine Montere
und überprüfen, wie ich Ihnen das war.
Ich sage der Krankenschweste,
Sie sollen Ihnen Blut abnehmen und machen wir einen EKG.
Und anschliessen,
werden wir einen Ultrischal.
Das ist gut, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Ihr anderer Kollege der Assistenzarzt hat nur geredet,
da hat nichts gemacht bisher.
Ja.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir schauen uns alles gleich an.
Ich bitte drum.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wenn Sie Burj Shmerzen bekommen,
die Geschichte noch etwas zur selben Zeit,
zum Beispiel Kalten Schweißigkeit,
Atemnot, Angst,
so ein Atemnot, enge Gefühle,
dann wird es mit der Luft schwierig
und wenn die Luft so knapp ist,
dann bekomme ich auch Panik.
Das ist richtig.
Haben Sie Herzrasen,
Herzstolpen,
Burj Shmerzen bekommen?
Wo Sie das so ansprechen,
ich bekomme dann auch Herzrasen.
Das stimmt, das merke ich.
Es bräuchte ganz kräftig.
Okay.
Wir haben Kollegen andere Fragen.
Sie sind noch mehr, hat sie da, Herr Oberarzt.
Ach Gott, das ist aber ein großes Krankenhaus hier.
Ja.
Also wir sind eine große Team,
hier steht 28 Ärzte.
Deswegen machen Sie keine Gedanken.
Wir stehen für Sie immer da.
Das ist aber schön.
Dann bin ich sehr froh,
dass ich zu Ihnen in dieses Krankenhaus gekommen bin.
Aber ich muss sagen,
Ihr Assistenzarzt ist sehr langsam.
Er hat nur geredet,
anstatt mich zu untersuchen.
Ich werde mich über ihn beschweren.
Nein, normalerweise funktioniert es so eine Anamnesieheben.
Das ist normal, Routine-Anamnesieheben.
Sie müssen alle Fragen stellen
und herausfinden, was Sie haben.
Ja, das ist echt etablich.
Das verstehe ich ja schon,
aber ich habe jetzt so ein Druckgefühl ge-
Aber gut, jetzt sind Sie gekommen.
Jetzt machen Sie die Untersuchung, dann ist es okay.
So, machen wir Arztgespräch.
Wo ist der Dring?
Ist abgehauen.
Ist weg.
So Herr Doktor, wie ist Ihr Name?
Herr Oberarzt, mein Name ist Jusof.
Ich bin Neuassistenarzt.
Herzlich willkommen.
Neue Kollege, herzlich willkommen.
Danke.
Jetzt möchte ich ein Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, natürlich.
Klaus Stein ist ein Brünhövierzig-Herrige im Patient.
Ist heute bei uns gekommen,
wegen seit 2 Tagen bestehende Dispne.
Als Begleit-Symptomer habe er Druckgefühl,
ohne Ausstrahlung.
Wo ist das Druckgefühl?
Druckgefühl angina, wie angina pectoris.
Aber wo ist das Druck?
In retros stanale Druckgefühl.
Im Heil, im Rücken, im Bauebene,
im Brustkorb, im Rechten, links.
Sie müssen das schon genau beschreiben.
Ja, retros stanale Russschmerzen.
Das hört sich schon besser an.
Ja, die Beschwerden seien bei Belastung verschlimmern.
Wie jetzt? Seien schlimmer oder verschlimmern sich?
Würden sich bei Belastung verschlimmern.
In den Lauf der Zeit sind hier Beschwerden schlimmer geworden.
Was ist der Druck oder die Luftnot?
Die Luftnot.
Erklagt über Tachikadi.
Er erwähnt eine geschwollene, linke Wade seit 2 Tagen.
Wie schnell ist die Tachikadi?
Was ist das für eine Tachikadi?
Eine Sinus-Tachikadi, Tachiaritmy.
Wie schnell ist die Frequenz?
Was ist die EKG rausgekommen?
Ich habe jetzt nur an amnestisch gefragt und
bitte von Schwestern ein EKG verschreiben lassen.
Haben Sie das noch nicht gemacht?
Herr Dr. Gündus, wie ist das EKG?
EKG, der Patient jetzt im EKG zwar.
Wo ist der Kardylobia?
Der hat doch einen EKG gemacht.
Dr. Mahmut, ist sie nicht da?
Nein.
Das EKG hat eine Sinus-Tachikadi mit eine Herzfrequenz von 120 pro Minute.
Alles klar.
Wie ist die Sauerstoffsättigung?
Nach dem an amnäßigen Gespräch werde ich Sauerstoffsättigung gemessen.
Das müssen Sie gleich machen.
96 Prozent.
96 Prozent, alles klar.
Okay.
Oder sagen wir, Entschuldigung, 93 Prozent.
Wie bitte?
Sauerstoffsättigung sind 93 Prozent.
93 Prozent.
Ja.
Die Frage nach Husten, Pyrosis.
Was ist Pyrosis?
Pyrosis.
Was ist das?
Okay. Pyrosis.
Vertigo.
Nose, Emesis, wurden vereint.
Er war nicht im Hausarzt wegen diese Beschwerden.
Vor allem die geschwollene Beine.
Und welche Beine wollen beide Beine?
Die linke Wade.
Die linke Wade ist geschwollene.
Also linke Unterschenke.
Ja.
Und habe keine dortige Temperatur-Unterschied bemerkt,
nur diese Schwellung.
Als Vorerkrankungen sind bei Ihnen eine Bandscheibe Vorfall-Diskuss-Kolapsus
vor zehn Jahren, der mit Krankengymnastik und Medikamente behandelt
und ein Covid im Februar bekannt.
Was ist mit Covid?
Eine Covid-Infektion?
Covid-Infektion.
Es wurde bei Ihnen keine Operationen durchgeführt.
Und Medikamente an einem Nese ist unaufwählig.
Allergie ist nicht bekannt.
Er rauche seit 20 Jahren, haltschachtel pro Tag.
Und wie viele Päckiers ist das?
10 Päckiers.
Er ist dreimal gegen Covid-19 geimpft und einmal genessen, wie ich gesagt habe.
In der Familie an Amnesien.
Prostata, Krankung und Materiehypertonie beim Vater bekannt.
Seine Mutter ist vor zwei Jahren gestorben.
Sie leidet auch an Diabetes.
Sie litt an Diabetes.
Er ist Einzelkind und Bauer vom Beruf.
Was ist der von Beruf?
Bauer, Bauarbeiter.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Ein Bauer ist ein Landwirt, der hat Tiere und ein Hof.
Das ist ein Bauer.
Ein Bauarbeiter arbeitet auf dem Bau.
Das ist meistens ein Handwerker.
So ist der Patient.
Ein Bauarbeiter.
Er hatte in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise.
Er war für acht Stunden beim Auto.
Eine Immobilität ist stet vor.
Ich gehe bei Herrn Sandstein aus der Analystik.
Er hat eine Lungenembolie bei TVT.
Die Fernsehldiagnostik.
Nach einer langen Reise.
Die Fernsehldiagnostik kommt ein Immokatin-Fakt im Betracht.
Er hat eine KG-Vermissung.
Ich nehme Blut ab.
Damit ich die Herzensiemen sehe.
Welche Laborwerte wollen Sie noch wissen?
Ich möchte die Dimmer-Spiegel zeigen.
Ich möchte für eine KG auszuschließen.
Ich möchte nicht nur einen Herzinfarkt auszuschließen.
Ich möchte nicht nur eine KG auszuschließen.
Ich möchte eine KG auszuschließen.
Ich möchte eine Lungenembolie bei TVT.
Ich möchte eine Stabilangehende-Pektoris.
Das ist eine Herzinfarkt-Geschichte.
Ich möchte eine Lungenembolie bei TVT.
Ich möchte eine Lungenemolie bei TVT.
Ich mache eine Monitoring.
Was machen Sie mit Antikorvalentzenterapie?
Wie verabreichen Sie das?
Ich muss die INR-Werte zeigen.
Wir beginnen davon aus.
Die Antikorvalentzenterapie ist sehr gut.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Ich verlege die Patienten noch auf die Intensivstation.
Welche Therapie-Optionen gibt es?
Eine Lüse-Therapie.
Man kann eine Trombos-Invasiv-Meter entfernen.
Ich kann Trombik-Tomy auch.
Ich werde Sie heute in die Ecke drängen.
Wie dosieren Sie das?
Nach welchen Kriterien?
Nach dem Kreislauf, Laburwerten, Gewicht?
Nein, es gibt keine Gerinnungsstörungen.
Nach APTT-Werte?
Vorhin kam der Hinweis, dass es das Gewicht von Patienten ist.
Sie sehen nicht den Körper.
Nach welchen Kriterien häparinisieren Sie nach Gewicht?
Nach der Kontrolle von Gerinnungsparameter.
Sie dosieren das häparin.
Sie können Intravenösers oder Subkutan geben.
Sie geben das Gewicht nach.
Sie geben das Subkutan.
Was?
Sie kennen einen Namen?
Sie kennen einen Niedermolekularer-Separin.
Sie geben das Gewicht nach.
Sie geben das Subkutan.
Sie haben einige fitte Kollegen.
Ich möchte mit Herrn Dr. Jussoff und den Kollegen reden.
Ich möchte Sie heute kritisieren.
Was ist Ihnen heute beim Doktor aufgefallen?
Sie haben einen Fehler gemacht.
Sie sprechen langsamer.
Sie haben eine Nervosität.
Sie haben ein Problem.